welcome to this video playing the Blitz
King from the US going for the English
Defence some stuff with f5 and b6 always
and leading to good fighting games let's
see hmm there are ways to play this with
this even I wonder that's not a very
common move on I don't think I can play
94 now okay i guess i can start with
this then 94 I wanted to control g5 hear
that that seems necessary so that I
takes f cake that's not flat g5 coming
oh he's actually taking interesting ok
so i can take on d5 takes takes but yes
night f5 which is kinda problematic
but maybe I can start with this if he
takes c6 there are many interesting ways
i mean i can play three for example for
it for interesting play was c5 is also
interesting c59 f5 you are not not
probably not see five where d txt
success is very risky anyway let's see
if he does that yeah he does it okay III
that's f 3 which is necessary c 59 f 5
okay i can actually just recapture this
is this is quite ok actually yeah this
na i can do that but it leads to it
leads to a pretty decent player black i
believe is playing this very quickly
very quickly like it's the most normal
thing in the world but i really don't
think so III of 395 is of course an
issue
yeah it is a substantial issue
okay i have to have to do this and now
this is this is really 95 as a problem
this it is difficult for me job to ever
take it this is really a really an issue
95 takes Queen takes and young I would
like to Castle long but he can give this
check on head okay yeah okay let's let's
do it I can give Bishop Aegis recheck oh
man what the game aah chak the I yes
Bishop hv trek is a great I really don't
think that this was any good for white I
mean maybe I'm just too optimistic about
all of that but let's look at this later
I don't think white can play like 94 94
and to lose tons of tempe but ok I've
really played it totally totally badly
and i'm lost now in his overtime yeah
have no move him Emily no move it really
doesn't matter and it's totally lost the
only thing is he cannot easily develop a
special at the moment but he can just
take material and win take d7 sampling
now I can just take twice now in g7 end
and I can take b6 can take be six no man
that this is frustrating really really
strange stuff and I'm just losing like a
little kid IAM check
yeah what a bad game so what should I
play they're actually gam oh I mean long
castles is definitely losing I with this
Bishop page 3 move and what should I
play and why is he not just taking this
it's kind of weird
yeah we should be too i know is totally
safe well yeah resigned this was really
really embarrassing him so how can i
play this i mean this is this is i don't
think this this can be any good but why
exactly how do i play this now so I
should just take it with an advantage
show maybe I was thinking that this
looks like is it looks dynamic but it it
really seems that that this job this is
even stronger okay I cannot do this it
looks dynamic but it's this is this is
good enough even this this kind of thing
is too strong so i suggest i should just
take this here this and black is just
fine this is just a weakness here and he
has no development yeah he's putting out
those moves what you did that just
premature taking 1.e4 but I mean what
our plate was just terrible am simply
not not refuting it here black is just
just clearly better I'm just winning the
55-year 95 d five years just dropping
and this is what happens if you take on
avoid you don't have any support for
this pawn on d5 I was just thinking I
should should should I was just thinking
that something dynamic would work but it
simply isn't he's backing up now trying
to do something but I mean it's just not
good not good play to take only for this
this point is just weak white is worse
in development so it's totally clear
that black has an advantage here not
quite sure what he's analyzing
i'm just a pawn up here for nothing and
simply i simply should have considered
this more and we now not quite sure what
that is just better here it's really
nothing to nothing to look he says no
yeah it's not my problem if you don't
understand the position you have a weak
corn on d5 baby you're just losing this
porn you're not developed if you don't
understand that that it's it's really
your problem okay whatever um he really
wants to analyze the sisters bazooey
very embarrassing for you okay Bishop
f6b to is saying you have got much
better development and you have a weak
central pawn on d5 like it's much better
here okay it's no use in arguing okay
well it was a bad game by me but at
least I know now what to do if this is
happening again thus capture on e4
shouldn't sacrifice all this stuff okay
thanks for watching